my mom doesn't like right
nice
like a vision board a super clarity
muscle like my name is Gary Vee Tom but
I've been telling you I'm triple a given
a pedigree meaning our special my
specialty
I'm putting the word go what's up
internation driving back to the city
right now this is a fun daily bean want
to make it a little collaboration with
me and you guys obviously a holiday
weekend
got some family time in and been really
debating if I really actually want to do
seven days a week of daily be obviously
the best up Sunday's are good but like
in a classic 4-day weekend like this
just for selfie phone video blogs not
sure if that's bringing you the most
value so I want to make this a special
feedback daily be I'm leaning towards
actually not doing every weekend
obviously some weekends go to Super Bowl
you know Jordan different things maybe
there's some reason for d-roc or Tyler
others oh I'm excited Tyler is gonna be
filming me this whole week to come you
know obviously South bys coming up you
that can will do that but I'm not sure I
want to do it every weekend obviously
I'm excited about the daily commitment
but I think one of the things I'm most
proud of is I changed my mind like you
know to me you know changing your mind
is such an important part of
entrepreneurship such a big part of my
strategy I don't fall in love with
anything obviously keeping your word is
different than changing your strategy in
mind and so I'm always balancing that
please don't get those two things
confused but for me here I think it's
important for me to bring value in the
blog form I love the idea of seven days
a week that's why I created biz dev
Sunday I thought that would take care of
that day I'm thrilled to keep going and
doing it I really am I guess I'm looking
for permission from you guys who I adore
so much how do you like these two three
four five six minute
very kind of raw it's a different look
you know Jordan you get a lot of face
time you're probably sad anyway would
love your feedback would love to see
what you guys think about the seven day
a week thing what should I do
what your thoughts are there any other
random thoughts leave a comment maybe uh
maybe Saturdays uh when we take a bunch
of highlight videos from fans and give
them shout outs it's a lot we can do
we'd love to get your two cents debating
the format by this week firm done locked
in randoms weekends when there's cool
stuff Superbowl Sunday as can locked in
firm but what about just kind of those
everyday weekend's is the perspective
from the phone two three four minute
rants face book lives based up Sunday's
little themes like that good enough or
or should we stick to
longer form stuff and take the weekends
off good luck your two cents leave three
if you want
[Music]